hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast or we discuss what it
means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua fields Milburn
and I am Ryan Nicodemus together we are
the minimalist welcome to episode 54 of
the minimalist podcast today we're going
to do a quickie episode and we're going
to talk about our friend stand it's one
of our best friends who was known was we
knew for a long time he passed away
three years ago this month and man holla
Lizzy he was 36 and who's four years
older than both of us but it seems
especially close to to us right now
because you and I will both be 36 this
year in later in the year and so
january2014 is is when he died and I
remember getting the news and I was just
I was shocked we meet her just starting
this tour and her first city yeah I was
a very first city and so I wrote an
essay about it that the night I got the
news and put it up on our website will
put a link to that in the show notes i
was hoping to read that and then ryan
maybe you and I could have a
conversation about the life that the
Stan lived and the lessons that we got
from from his legs because his was a a
profound albeit too short life for sure
this this essay is called live like Stan
the traffic light hanging above our car
is a blur of red tears are burning my
eyes Ryan is seated in the passenger
seat next to me he too was teary-eyed
it's the eve of our big hundred city
book tour the Florida Sun has already
set behind the tampa bay night fall is
upon us now by the time the traffic
light changes it's just a mess of wet
green a shapeless emerald cloud spilling
into the nighttime ether i received the
call a moment earlier the news a week
after Ryan avoided his own death which
we can talk about in a moment the week
after Ryan avoided his own death one of
my closest friends Stanley Dukes is dead
this isn't going to be easy to write
overwhelmed with unanswerable questions
I feel a canyon of sorrow I can't see
past the tears he was only 36 years old
so I'm compelled to pin a thousand
cliches life is too short every day is a
gift you never know when you're going to
go so live your life to the fullest
while these truisms our apt the truth is
that Stan lived more in his three and a
half decades that most people could in a
hundred years Stanley Dukes was a Mozart
of positive living and so his attenuated
life was not in vain of course this
doesn't erase the pain but it makes it
easier to handle we met in the corporate
world a decade ago at first when I was a
regional manager Stan worked for me as a
store manager but he was so talented he
added so much value to so many lives
that I often felt as though I worked for
him although he managed dozens of
employees his genius was most pronounced
in his ability to inspire people who
were not self-motivated which if you
know anything about leading people is
sort of like convincing water to be less
wet but somehow he did it always
carrying with him a smile and his
positive mental attitude as a result he
was one of the most successful managers
in the entire company over time we
became close friends we shared similar
values and beliefs as well as tastes and
literature and movies and music I traded
him overwrought short stories for his
hilarious pseudonymous erotic fiction we
exchanged lines from Glengarry Glen Ross
characters and we both shared a healthy
obsession for John Mayer's music we
became so close that he is even the
first person to make appearance in my
memoir everything that remains where he
pops his huge lovable head into the very
first page and here's a an excerpt from
from that book our identities are shaped
by the costumes we
I am seated in a cramped conference room
surrounded by ghosts and searched shirt
sleeves and pleated trousers there are
35 maybe 40 people here middle managers
a lot of us mostly Caucasian mostly male
all oozing apathy the group's medium
complexion is that of an agoraphobe a
microsoft excel spreadsheet is projected
onto an oversized canvas pulled from the
ceiling at the front of the room the
canvas is flimsy flimsy and cracked and
is the shade of off-white that suggests
it's a relic from a time when employees
were allowed to smoke indoors the rest
of the room is aggressively white the
walls are white the ceiling is white the
people are white as if all cut from the
same materials well everyone except Stan
seated at the back of the room
Cincinnati's population is forty five
percent black but stan is part of our
company's single-digit percentage his
comments though rarely solicited by
executives are often dismissed with a
nod and a pain smile although he's the
size of an NFL linebacker stan is a
paragon of kindness but that doesn't
stop me from secretly hoping that one
day he'll get set up with the
patronizing grins and make it his duty
to reformat one of the bosses fish-eyed
faces of course Stanwood and now we're
back to the the text here back to the
essay of course Stan wouldn't have
touched a hair on any of their balding
heads he was above that he was above all
the petty BS we get caught up in every
day he was above living life based on
other people's standards his standards
were too high for that he had character
Stan contributed beyond himself each
year at Christmas time he dressed up as
Santa and handed out gifts to our
employees he spent many off hours
donating his time the soup kitchens and
Habitat for Humanity and last year he
founded a mentorship conference for
young men ages 13 to 18 Stan cared when
I decided to leave the corporate world
three years ago he didn't flinch instead
he was the first to join me we walked
away together guided by solidarity and a
kinship that's impossible to manufacture
before I moved to Montana we met for
coffee weekly our visit she Oded
heartfelt advice on women and life as
well as arguments over which john mayer
album was best he said it was a battle
studies and I said it was heavier things
so I don't know if you agree or disagree
with other of those but I feel that I'm
right well everything about Stan
reflected a profound truth even his
simple tweets were steeped in pro funda
tea here's a selection of some of his
tweets I have here a man can't walk out
of his own story that one was like the
most painful for me Ryan like Chris just
was I think it was his final tweet
actually well let's see secure your own
mask before assisting others and he
lived that by the way I'm he helped
other people first or he helped he helps
other people but he made sure his life
was together first and then helped other
people rather next week was there's a
bright spot in every shadow next week
was it's the bitter and the sweet I know
the bitter and that allows me to
appreciate the suite next week only your
actions can prove your worth they tell
people who you are and then souther one
here this one was was simple but so true
don't drown in conformity and sand fo
didn't conform it's the reason he
decided to leave the corporate world
yeah with me let's finish this essay
here it's almost over countless essays
on this site were inspired by my
conversation with Stan our final
conversation was mimetic of his life it
was short but meaningful three days
before Thanksgiving I sent him a message
I said I don't have to wait until
thursday to be thankful for you I'm
grateful you're in my life every day to
which he replied succinctly thanks for
that please know that I feel the same
Stan lived until he died he truly lived
every day not like most of us
to walk through life like it's some kind
of dress rehearsal worrying about bs
that doesn't matter nope Stan was alive
one of the only people I know who didn't
take this life for granted if there's a
lesson to be learned here it's that like
Stan we're all going to die but few of
us will ever be courageous enough to
live as he did honest well-rounded
passionate positive and constantly
improving above all Stan dukes was good
people a man I aspire to live like that
green blur overhead is my signal to step
on the gas to wipe the tears and move
forward perhaps you'll do likewise I
know Stan wood sorry to read that man oh
no this hard community here I mean it's
I think about it a lot it was everything
I would have those emotions three years
later man but he he still shows up and
dreams a lot for me yeah you not talked
about this in the past at least
privately but man he was such a good
friend and I can't help but think like
if he was still around he'd be out here
in Montana with us he probably would
because I'm fairly certain of it and you
know we would be able to he was he was
so good at helping other people
especially people who as I said neyo say
who who were sort of uninspired he
inspired the uninspiring in a way and he
did so in a way I remember some of the
people that worked for him he had a way
of just telling it how it was without
coddling them but but helping them see
that there was a brighter future for
them if they wanted to embrace that yeah
I hate to admit this but he was on the
floor more like when I say on the floor
he was on the sales floor like imma
front lines working with his guys more
than any other manager that I bet I saw
including myself I'm not probably number
two
but uh but now I am I really respected
him for that and he was one of the most
supportive people I've ever known yeah I
was like you know as you're reading that
i'm reminiscing about my times with Stan
and I II just has been he was with us
through everything with me through
everything like you know my 25 year old
year old self antics him and I were were
always out you know chasing girls and
you know whatever uh-huh um but then you
know later in life you know when we
started the minimalists and stuff I mean
he was there to to support me in that
way as well he was it's funny because I
often talk about people who I stopped
hanging out with because they were just
my drinking buddies or they were like
you know my going out buddies and it
wasn't like I stopped going out from
because in the like him anymore I just
didn't want to have this habit well like
Stan was not one of those guys like he
was one of those guys who he was like
yeah you know I'm not gonna do this
anymore i'm going to try and incorporate
other habit to my life and he's like
yeah me too and I remember like having
this conversation with him and I was
like yeah you know like I really want to
get healthier and yeah I'm to think
about doing this juice fast like he's a
I think I'd have done juice fast before
that but the longest juice fast i have
ever been on it was because of stan like
he challenged me for ten days um we we
were there to like support each other i
was going i was looking at our text the
other day i don't know why they came up
but uh but i was looking just kind of
like reminiscing um conversations we had
and I was just like going through that
that stint of where we were on that
juice fast how like if it was not for
staying I don't think I would have made
it ten days yeah you know yeah man it's
uh I think about so he died he had a
heart attack at age 36 and he was a big
guy NFL linebacker size guy and he had
heart problems even though and he was
living a very healthy life when you get
idea I mean it was point of the Jews
fats like he was going out of his way to
like exercise and like eat healthy he
did another juice fast after that 10-day
juice fast uh-huh like a week or so
later and I was like dude you're crazy
and he was just such an example for me
of not getting cop into my new show
embracing the my news report I mean we
all have to check email if that's part
of our life or will hop on social media
but not getting buried by the minutia
and so he would he would embrace those
things and and and it's not that he
completely issued technology or anything
like that it was it was the opposite he
embraced it he moved on from it he
didn't let it control his life he let it
be tools in his own life and I learned
so many lessons from him like I said
early on the first several years first
what three years of the website really a
lot of that was inspired by
conversations at you and I had had with
him yeah I would meet at press and
Dayton Ohio every week and just sit
there in the back and trade stories and
and I found I found to be inspirational
because we were on the same same
wavelength and so I was a pedagogical
relationship i felt like i was teaching
him and he was teaching me at the same
time and when you got that yen in the
yang were you're both learning and
you're both teaching it it just feels it
feels amazing and I'm so sad to see him
gone I still think about him all the
time and I wish she was back here but I
can tell you this I look at his life as
a template for for loving my own in a
way and realizing that my god we're all
going to die we're going to go and and
the question is can live my best life
right now with all the troubles i have
the health issues I have with with any
of the issues that we have on our life
can we embrace the life for what it is
the life that we have and live that best
version of it because eventually will be
gone all together no matter what you
leave believe in about you know the
afterlife or whatever this life is is
going to be gone and so can we make the
best of it while we're here yeah what
things is the best one of the best ways
we can honor Stan yeah is shared
memories like this I'm really glad that
we decided to do this yeah me too so I
think
I was a probably good place to end at
Shawn we can we can go from here
[Music]